ellos son parte de los ciudadanos que
salieron a marchar en diversas regiones
del perú no aceptan a manuel merino como
presidente del país y rechaza que martín
vizcarra haya sido destituido al repudio
ciudadano quiere expresar que no
consideran a merino como presidente
legítimo porque afirman no cuentan con
el respaldo de la población no aceptamos
a manuel merino no lo aceptamos no no de
ninguna manera es un golpista este golpe
es viene del congreso es increíble que
que casi 20 años de continuidad
electoral democrática venga en estos
últimos 5 años una serie de hechos
totalmente anti burocráticos desde el
congreso los manifestantes sostienen que
la vacancia presidencial no es la mejor
forma de solucionar los problemas del
perú y señalan que la actitud del
parlamento y de manuel merino seguirá
siendo respondida con protestas en las
calles
lo que nosotros esperamos ahora es que
la comunidad internacional vea que esto
llegue a oídos internacionales que el
perú se está desestabilizando y no por
nosotros sino por las personas que
supuestamente representan a la patria
en medio de la pandemia el coi 19 que
aún no ha sido controlado y por si esto
fuera poco ha saltado también por el
colapso económico pero se enfrasca en
una nueva crisis política que para
algunos podría extenderse durante la
gestión del presidente manuel merino